the House unanimously is calling for the
Justice Department to release the
special counsels Russia collusion report
once it's finished there are new
indications tonight that might be very
soon here's chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Harridge a
spokesman for Special Counsel Muller
confirms that top prosecutor Andrew
Weissman is stepping down in what may be
the latest clue the Russia investigation
is winding down but the timing also
reflects that former campaign chairman
Paul mana fourth sentencing is now
complete in DC and Virginia Weitzman was
the lead prosecutor and Weitzman was
also in court today as political
operative Roger stone learned his trial
date is set for November 5th on the
House floor with rare bipartisan support
lawmakers voted in favor of a
non-binding resolution to encourage
Attorney General William bark to release
molars full report to both Congress and
the country resolution will send a clear
signal to both the American people and
to the Department of Justice that
Congress believes transparency is a
fundamental principle necessary to
ensure that government remains
accountable to the public the special
counsel statute known as 28 CFR 600
mandates that Moeller sent a
confidential report to the Attorney
General
during confirmation hearings Barr laid
bare his interpretation telling
lawmakers he would summarize nuts and
molars findings to Congress and release
as much as possible to the public it's
nothing but a restatement of the
regulation attorney general Barr will
follow the regulation he is the lead
Republican on the Judiciary Committee
Doug Collins also released more
transcripts from a House probe into the
2016 actions of the FBI and DOJ FBI
agent Peter Strahm dismissed from the
special counsel for his antitrump text
told lawmakers Muller never pressed him
on political bias Republican John
Radcliffe asked did you have any
discussion with special counsel Muller
or the other attorney about whether or
not those text messages reflected bias
or prejudice against Donald Trump struck
no according to the struct transcript
there was also a negotiated consent
agreement between the Justice Department
and Clinton lawyers that lay down ground
rules
for FBI access to her personal servers
used for State Department business those
servers also contained Clinton
Foundation email spread Kevin Thank You
Malcolm